[Applaudissements]
merci à toi
retenez bien ce chiffre
selon l'aspect tricher qui ont mené une
étude en 2017
35000 correspond au nombre de décisions
que nous prenons en moyenne par jour
je m'appelle Guillaume Mathias je suis
expert en neurosciences et en sciences
cognitive de façon un petit peu moins
barbare mon métier consiste à étudier
comment fonctionne le cerveau humain
pour comprendre comment nous en tant
qu'individu on va se mettre en mouvement
pour pouvoir s'adapter à nos
environnements et qui sont en perpétuel
changement
35000 décisions c'est colossal mais de
quoi on parle exactement et bien 35000
fois dans la journée
votre cerveau va devoir trouver des
stratégies adaptatives pour pouvoir
s'adapter on est des organismes vivants
et si vous prenez un organisme vivant
qui n'a pas de capacité d'adaptation à
combien même l'environnement change
qu'est-ce qui se passe il meurt donc on
a la chance de pouvoir se mettre en
mouvement pour pouvoir s'adapter et
survivre
35 000 décisions par jour
je sais pas si vous avez tous comme ça
la sensation de décider de choix
adaptatif 35000 fois par jour moi
personnellement pas du tout
et pour cause
99,74 % de vos décisions
échappent totalement à votre conscience
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
alors qu'on est justement en train
d'étudier la thématique keep control
et bien c'est que
99,74% des choses que vous faites
vous n'aurez pas le contrôle c'est votre
cerveau qui va le déclencher
automatiquement vous le conscientisez
pas et donc ça échappe à votre capacité
de contrôle
là-dessus sur la thématique on est en
train de se dire waouh c'est pas gagné
on va essayer de se rassurer on va
essayer d'être un petit peu optimiste
quand même dans tout il nous reste 0,26%
des décisions
là c'est moi qui décide
[Musique]
on va tempérer un petit peu ça puisque
depuis mars 2019 avec les travaux qui
ont été réalisés notamment par Joël
Pierson mars 2019 donc et bien on est
capable de pouvoir prédire la décision
que va prendre une personne
en la mettant dans un scanner et RMF ça
nous permet de pouvoir observer
l'activité cérébrale du sujet de le
mettre dans un contexte décisionnel et
dans ce contexte là en observant le
fonctionnement de son cerveau on va
pouvoir prédire la décision qu'il va
prendre jusqu'à 11 secondes avant que le
sujet lui-même en est conscience
je vous laisse cogiter la signification
de ça
je vois vos regards blême
puis des blême que oui ce que je suis en
train de vous dire c'est que dans 100%
des cas votre cerveau décide avant vous
et que Monsieur daigne bien vouloir dans
0,26% des cas
nous en informer
keep control
alors
je vais vous présenter
c'est dans l'autre sens je vais vous
présenter
moi et mon cerveau
moi et mon cerveau vous avez peut-être
l'impression que dans mon discours et a
juste titre qui a une petite base un
petit peu schizophrénique comme si on
était deux dans ma tête
on est plus que ça mais c'est un autre
sujet
et bien c'est peut-être pas si faut que
ça
ce qui va faire la différence entre moi
et mon cerveau
moi qu'est-ce que c'est sur la
thématique suis-je vraiment à l'origine
de mes décisions le jeu le moi et bien
ce mot là c'est pas la totalité du
cerveau
c'est principalement une partie qu'on
appelle le cortex préfrontal qui se
situe ici hors chez moi c'est bien on le
voit bien qui est basé ici qui en rebond
avec d'autres structures corticales va
faire permettre de faire venir la
conscience de soi la conscience
d'exister c'est un pouvoir absolument
fabuleux
juste pour s'amuser comme ça vous avez
déjà réalisé que le cerveau est le seul
organe qui a pu choisir son nom
le foie n'a jamais le choix mais c'est
bien votre cerveau qui a choisi votre
son nom et bien cette capacité là ce
pouvoir là qui est juste extraordinaire
un défaut malgré tout
c'est qu'avec son super pouvoir il a
l'impression d'être le tout
en fait il ne sait pas très bien où il
commence et où s'arrête non seulement il
a l'impression d'être effectivement le
préfontal mais le cerveau mais également
le reste du corps quand je vous montre
ma main comme ça en faisant Coucou On a
bien conscience que c'est ma main c'est
moi
mais si je me coupe un doigt
est-ce que je suis un peu moins moi
non ça reste pas moins enfin ça reste
moi tout simplement parce que mon doigt
n'est pas constitutif
de la conscience de soi
et maintenant qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi est-ce que mon cerveau et
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai l'impression
que si mon cerveau ne m'en informe pas
et bien que ce n'est pas moi et bien
c'est que
99,74 % des déclenchements de mise en
mouvement ne passe pas dans cette zone
du cerveau et comme ça ne passe pas
dedans ça ne marche pas ma conscience je
n'ai pas l'impression que ça vient de
moi
c'est la frontière très traité ténue
notamment qu'on va retrouver dans la
théorie freudienne du conscient et de
l'inconscient
à faire un petit truc pour essayer de
toucher du doigt cette frontière entre
les deux vous avez tous conscience que
on se parle en permanence dans notre
tête
ouais
vous entendez tout cette voix dans votre
tête
alors rassurez-vous c'est tout à fait
normal à la condition que ça soit votre
voix
si c'est pas votre voix vous entendez
c'est un autre problème on pourra en
parler plus tard
je vous dis que c'est normal mais
vous avez déjà réalisé à quel point
c'est bizarre de se parler
c'est super bizarre si vous vous parlez
c'est bien que vous avez construit la
phrase
si vous avez construit la phrase
nécessairement vous saviez ce que vous
vouliez vous dire
faute de quoi vous n'auriez pas pu
construire la phrase
alors si vous saviez ce que vous voulez
vous dire pourquoi vous vous parlez
c'est à peu près aussi tordu que prendre
son téléphone portable tiens je m'écrire
un texto je me l'envoie je le poste mon
Dieu qu'est-ce que je me suis écrit je
ne sais pas encore je ne l'ai pas lu
et pourtant c'est bel et bien ce qu'on
fait
à mon goût vous allez commencer une
phrase vous allez vous parler de quelque
chose vous dites ce que vous voulez par
exemple les tordu ce chauve la marche
aussi mais quand je vous dis stop vous
arrêtez net ok attention 3 2 1 Go stop
qu'est-ce que vous voulez vous dire
et ben justement vous êtes obligé de
finir la phrase pour savoir ce que vous
voulez vous dire
pourquoi
et bien justement parce que pension du
message se situe en dehors de cette zone
du cerveau
mais cette intention il va bien falloir
trouver un moyen de la faire passer dans
les aires corticales responsables de la
conscience et le langage est une
modalité de représentation une modalité
qui va permettre de faire passer le flux
d'intention dont la champ de la
conscientisation c'est effectivement
pour ça qu'on se parle
alors rassurez-vous c'est tout à fait
normal
maintenant si on regarde un petit peu
moi et mon cerveau
la différence qui va y avoir entre
perception
et donc entre mon cerveau et moi et bien
mon cerveau on l'a vu il agit très très
vite
puisque il est capable de prendre une
décision avant que j'en ai conscience
son temps son action va être
majoritairement de percevoir d'évaluer
et de déclencher les passages à l'action
ce qu'on appelle en anglais généralement
le PVA perception va lui action action
qui va s'opérer à peu près en 40 entre
40 et 230 millisecondes ça dépend des
différents champs en tout cas c'est très
très rapide et ça se passe avant qu'on
en est conscience et ensuite ça va être
poussé dans 0,26% des cas dans le champ
de conscientisation c'est effectivement
le goût quand vous prenez une décision
que vous rationalisez la décision
que ça va être poussé à votre champ de
conscience
jusque là
ça va à peu près
là où ça se complique c'est quand on
commence à faire la différence entre les
champs de perception et les champs de
représentation
c'est pas le tout de s'adapter à des
environnements
il faut déjà les percevoir ces
environnements et pour percevoir les
environnements on a besoin de nos sens
nos sens vont être des récepteurs qui
lorsqu'ils sont en contact de certaines
informations one steep stimuler et
envoyer une impulsion électrique au
cerveau
on arrive ici et là il faut savoir que
mon cerveau reçoit à peu près 11
millions d'unités d'informations par
seconde
OK et ça va rejoindre un énorme bain
d'information et à peu près 400 c'est ça
400 milliards d'unités
mais en revanche il y en aura que 2000
qui seront portés à ma conscience
soit 0,00
1% je crois je me plante tout le temps
dans les 0
donc c'est un film
mais ce qui est porté à ma confiance on
est bien d'accord que vous ne recevez
pas juste des 0 et des 1 on en sauvez
pas juste des impulsions électriques
c'est une traduction notre cerveau se
crée une représentation de ce qui est
une représentation des environnements
dans lesquels on évolue et que signifie
le mot représentation et bien c'est
quelque chose qui est représenté
représenter à nouveau dans notre tête ce
qui est à l'extérieur
et on ne peut vivre que dans le champ de
représentation on déclenche nos
stratégies adaptatives volontaires en
fonction de ce qui est dans notre tête
est-ce que ce qui est dans notre tête
est fidèle à ce qui est rien n'est sûr
on va juste s'amuser rapidement pour que
vous puissiez prendre conscience que
vous vivez dans les environnements que
vous construisez dans votre tête donc là
je vous envoie un flux perceptif qui
reste constant il ne change pas on a des
tâches violettes on en a une qui
disparaît successivement de façon
circulaire et on a une croix noire au
milieu ça c'est le flux d'information
perceptif maintenant je vous invite à
fixer la croix noire et à ne surtout pas
portez votre regard sur votre chose
fixez bien la croix noire vous
n'entendez plus que le son de ma voix
non je déconne non fixez bien la croix
noire
qu'est-ce qui va se passer
et bien les points violets effectivement
vont disparaître au profit d'une tâche
verte qui tourne autour de la croix
noire votre cerveau change la
représentation du flux de perception
ce n'est possible que parce que vous
vivez dans la représentation qui est
construite dans votre tête mal à la
seconde vous allez vouloir porter votre
regard sur le point vert il disparaît et
les points violets reviennent ok allez
juste un petit deuxième juste pour le
plaisir nous avons ici deux phases d'un
cube on est bien d'accord
et bien on a un cube dont le centre est
ici
on a un gris foncé et ainsi on a un
blanc gris clair on est d'accord avec ça
et bien j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle pour
vous c'est que les deux faces du cube
sont exactement de la même couleur
pour pouvoir vous en assurer je vous
invite avec le doigt comme ça ou deux
doigts à venir masquer cette zone là
et effectivement instantanément
s'aperçoit que ces deux temps exactement
de la même couleur on change le flux
perceptible vous allez changer
mécaniquement le flux perceptif et votre
cerveau va changer la façon qui va avoir
de le traduire
retenez bien ça on vit donc si on veut
étudier comment un individu s'adapte à
ses environnements il faut pas chercher
à étudier comment il s'adapte à ce qui
est autour de lui mais à la façon dont
ils se les représente puisqu'il s'adapte
aux environnements qui existent dans sa
tête
moi et mon cerveau donc mon cerveau
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire il va créer une
passionnéisation
des environnements qu'il perçoit
une rationalisation c'est quoi et ben
c'est de faire en sorte que cause
conséquence puisse se suivre ah
supérieur AB si a supérieur AB est
supérieur acné tous en coeur normalement
vous me répondez alors c'est supérieur à
a c'est ce qu'on appelle une
rationalisation
et donc pendant toute la période du 20e
siècle
tu me manques convaincu
que nous étions des acteurs sociaux
économiques rationnels
que nous répondions à la logique de la
raison on a défini on est conscience
économique en sciences sociales l'acteur
homo économique
et nous avons développé des
environnements d'interaction entre nous
ou avec la société basée sur la raison
jusqu'à ce que à peu près dans les
années 80 émergent la notion de
vraiment rationnel
je vais donner juste quelques exemples
qui vont vous parler très très
rapidement
donc un visuel
ces gens-là payent pour faire du sport
rigolez pas trop
on connaît tous des fumeurs qui mangent
bio
ça fait partie des états irrationnels
que faire du sport c'est super important
pour la santé
qui considère faire suffisamment de
sport chaque jour
nous sommes des acteurs sociaux
économiques irrationnel
c'est effectivement ce qui a émergé dans
les années 80-90 sauf que dans cette
période-là difficile de comprendre
pourquoi et avec l'émergence des
neurosciences et des sciences cognitives
et bien on a pu approfondir ces gens-là
pourquoi nous sommes des acteurs
socio-économiques irrationnels parce que
nous répondons et ce qui va déclencher
la stratégie adaptative dans ce laps de
temps des 40 à 230 millisecondes
répondent non pas à la raison mais la
logique du vivant la logique du vivant
c'est quoi et bien sous les structures
sous corticales on va faire simple dans
le système limbique not Islam olympique
va étudier si quelque chose est bon ou
pas pour nous mais pas par rapport à la
raison par rapport à des états
physiologiques on est des organismes
vivants on doit maintenir des équilibres
internes qu'on appelle des états
homéostatiques
si jamais il commence à avoir un
déséquilibre trop important alors va se
créer en moi des tas de tension
et c'est cette attention vont me mettre
en mouvement sans tension pas de
mouvement
et donc ces mouvements sont bien là pour
développer des stratégies adaptatives
pour maintenir mes équilibres internes
dans ces équilibres internes on va avoir
des situations qui vont être qui vont
générer de la version
la douleur par exemple la couleur c'est
quoi c'est une sensation c'est une
perception une on appelle ça la
nocesception c'est une sensation dans
lesquelles je suis très aversif et parce
que j'en suis averti ça crée un état de
tension interne en moi qui va m'obliger
à réagir pour que cette état de tension
et de déséquilibre cesse et que je
puisse retrouver un équilibre interne on
a exactement la même chose sur des
choses qui sont à l'inverse très
positives comme le circuit de la
récompense avec le circuit
dopaminergique qui va nous amener à
aller chercher à maximiser des plaisirs
l’ocytocine qui va nous amener à créer
du lien entre nous la sérotonine qui
nous donne la conscience d'exister la
nécessité d'être et bien d'oser la
notion de bonheur les endorphines on
plane avec les endorphines
et tout ça vont être des déclencheurs
physiologiques neurologiques c'est
également ça la conséquence de ces
productions non seulement vont permettre
de rétablir les états internes mais les
ressentis physiologiques sont les
origines même de vos émotions
lorsque je prends un gros shoot de
dopamine ah la notion de plaisir lorsque
je prends un gros shoot de sérotonine la
fierté je suis
etc etc mais ça ne répond pas à la
raison on le sait très bien quand on
commence à toucher au paquet de
cacahuètes on en mange pas qu'une
et pourtant c'est pas raisonnable le
carré de chocolat
est passée ce qui va se passer derrière
un petit exemple
sentez bien l'état aversif je la laisse
pas longtemps
il est trop mignon mais dans les deux
cas c'est totalement irrationnel vous le
savez ce sont des photos
c'est des images ce qui nous met en
mouvement n'est pas à la raison ce sont
ces états physiologiques
ce qui se passe ici
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a autant de
tension pourquoi est-ce qu'on nous dit
qu'il faut garder le contrôle c'est
parce qu'on vit en société et que si on
lâchait les chevaux juste sur les
déclencheurs ça serait un KO absolu
heureusement pour nous dans la partie
préfrontale dans la partie
orbitofrontale on a ce qu'on appelle des
régulateurs des inhibiteurs ils vont
être là nécessairement pour tempérer ces
réactions là oui mais maintenant comme
on doit évoluer en permanence dans une
société qui a été rationalisée et en
intensifie les flux en intensifie la
vitesse en intensifie tout ce qu'on peut
dans un contexte rationnel
l'interaction avec des acteurs
irrationnels ce qui pousse un hyper
control un hyper inhibition et cette
hyper inhibition va produire beaucoup
enfin à nécessite beaucoup d'énergie et
nous amène parfois à trop vouloir
contrôler et bien tout simplement à
s'épuiser surcharge mentale dépression
burn out stress chronique
en 2003 c'est le professeur Herbert si
je dis pas de bêtises qui disait que 80%
des consultations médicales étaient
liées au stress chronique à la surnécité
de contrôle et d'adaptation qui amène
l'organisme à s'épuiser à vouloir se
contrôler au maximum pour essayer de
caler à la rationalisation de nos
entreprises alors en mot de la fin
oui c'est important de garder le
contrôle de savoir exactement sur quoi
on veut le porter pour tempérer les
choses ça c'est ce que nous on peut
faire mais deuxième réflexion c'est de
commencer à réfléchir comment sortir de
l'hyper rationalisation de nos
environnements du 20e siècle pour
commencer à adapter nos organisations et
nos environnements non plus à la raison
mais à la logique du vivant
clip control mais pas trop merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]